the 139th US Open starts here in New
York City next week and Niomi Osaka one
of the biggest names in tennis will
defend her title at just 21 years old
she is the second highest paid female
athlete in the world that's according to
Forbes Osaka won last year's open
defeating tennis legend Serena Williams
on her way to back-to-back Grand Slam
victories vladimir duthiers of our
streaming service cbsn caught up with
the number one ranked player ahead of
next week's tournament kind of consider
I think New York is home it's one of my
favorite cities in the world and
whenever I come back I just feel
instantly comfortable describing Niomi
Osaka's game to those who've never
watched her play isn't difficult
she's a whirlwind of competitive
intensity balanced by external poise and
grace given your hyper-competitiveness
how important was it that you were
ranked the number one female tennis
player in the world it's always been a
dream you know I think that's one of the
things that like little kid tennis
players look forward to we want to win
Grand Slam so we want to be number one
at only 21 years old
she's already reached the pinnacle of
her sport when we met her in New York
she was in the middle of a press event
for body armor sports drink do you think
that that pressure is that internal or
is that external yeah I mean the
internal pressures are as bad ok and
what I lie when I say that because I
just realized like I do put a lot of
pressure on myself because you know
having the number-one ranking means that
you're supposed to be the best you had a
very personal Instagram post where you
called the last few months the worst of
your life what happened that made you
feel that way when you wrote that for
tennis players we train so hard just for
that one moment or that one match on the
court it's just really high high if you
win or a really low low if you lose
after winning back-to-back Grand Slam
titles Lusaka
lost her next two majors in July she was
eliminated from Wimbledon in the very
first round one of the biggest things
I've learned over the summer is just to
keep getting back up
believe in yourself and have fun and
tennis is fun I think there are moments
where it stops being fun for me but then
I realized that I'm super grateful to be
in the position that I'm in despite
Osaka soaring celebrity and influence
she's grounded and credits tennis legend
Serena Williams a lifelong role model
now I have this huge respect for her
it's someone that I've you know looked
up to my entire life so I still feel a
bit shocked whenever she reaches out and
I don't know I don't say hi to her or
anything
what god I get so nervous really yeah
and she always seems like she's doing
something important so I don't want to
interrupt and then I really want to talk
to her about life and stuff and like how
she manages to do things on and off the
court but so I don't want to be
disrespectful to her and like try to
talk to her like she's my mentor while
she's still playing so I'm kind of just
chilling on that do you think you would
reach out to her just to see I mean I
would but I do you feel like you're a
peer of hers well you don't feel like
you're a peer I would have to win twenty
something more Grand Slam to be her peer
she has so many lists of accomplishments
oh no way I've just been very grateful
that I'm even playing I've been trying
to like take every day as a new
experience and learn from everything
what an amazing in candid interview yes
it's very revealing it's me and she's
only how much pressure you put on
yourself at 21 I can't imagine putting
that kind of pressure yeah this is
complicated feelings to this game that
she placed so well yeah well it's great
to see how humble she is yes how she's
afraid to say hi to Serena I'm sure
Serena would love to talk comes over and
uh shakes hands and makes a date I'm
alright well